Ukraїner
[Експедиція]
♪ За горою зайчики трублять, ♪
♪  чого ж мене хлопці не люблять? ♪
♪ Ой складе збивки по грошу, ♪
[Полісся
хутір Старі Коні]
♪ купить мені жичку
[шерстяна або шовкова стрічка] хорошу. ♪
♪ Ой складе збивки по грошу, ♪
♪ купить мені жичку хорошу. ♪
♪ Як я буду жичку носити, ♪
♪ будуть мене хлопці любити. ♪
[Доминіка Чекун]
[собака гавкає]
Люблю співати змалку сама.
Мене ніхто не навчав.
Бог дає так.
От,  мама на поле піде,
полити там [розсаду].
І я дивлюся — навчуся так.
До Пасхи не співають на дворі.
Після Пасхи вже співають на дворі весну.
Ще тиждень після Трійці можна співати.
А тоді вже починається літо.
Уже літні пісні співаємо.
Успення минуло  — то закінчується літо.
І вже співаємо осінні пісні.
Поляки приїжджають.
Вони вже більше ста пісень
записали та вивчили.
Уже вони концерти роблять самі, без нас.
♪ Я посію мак, ♪
♪ да посію мак над водою, ♪
♪ да заріс мій мак лободою. ♪
♪ Ой заріс мій мак, ♪
♪ да заріс мій мак лободою, ♪
♪ ой вийшла заміж молодою. ♪
Пісня повинна бути тужливою.
Тужлива пісня  — життєва.
Кожна має свій голос.
У кожному селі — свій наспів.
Комори [сусіднє село] недалеко.
Але там трошки не так, як у нас, співають.
Ми по-іншому, і вони по-іншому співають.
І не дуже вони далеко.
[Полісся
село Комори]
Я його не знала.
Він з армії щойно прийшов,
а я не знала, що він взагалі існує.
Цей кавалер.
[Сміються]
[Микола Васькевич]
Ішли з клубу. Він до мене вчепився  — і все.
[Тетяна Васькевич]
Пішов, пішли, та й пішло діло.
Тож три роки зустрічалися, не рік.
Три роки зустрічалися.
Але я взагалі не знала, який він,
і що він взагалі є на світі.
А тоді прийшов уже з армії.
З армії щойно прийшов.
Знаєте, як це, коли хлопець з армії прийде.
Влюбилася.
[Сміються]
І от подивіться, як воно.
Ніякого весілля не було.
У нього мати одна.
І в мене батька не було,
бо помер ще в 40 років.
♪ Ой гай-батьку, ой гай-мати, ♪
♪ Ой гай зелененький, ♪
♪ примандрував на Вкраїну
козак молоденький. ♪
Співай!
Не можу низько співати.
А я вище не можу.
♪ Примандрував, шапку зняв,
низенько схилився: ♪
♪ Прощай мені, вся родино,
бо я оженивсь. ♪
Село веселе було.
Таке співоче, таке веселе.
Завжди сходилися до магазину.
Зараз ні магазину, нічого нема.
Залишилося, може, 35 людей у ньому.
[Полісся
село Сваловичі]
Ой співали — співали.
Гарно тут співали українські пісні.
Але щось горло стало дерти —
уже не так виходить.
♪ Ой помию я звечора ніжки, ♪
[Катерина Труш]
♪ Бо прийдеться на землю ступати, ♪
♪ Бо прийдеться з милим розставатися. ♪
♪ Ох як тяжко любов забувати. ♪
Стара баба.
[Сміється]
У мене тут нікого нема, одна я.
Немає у мене ні корови, ні свиней,
ні курей, — нічого.
З пенсії, що отримаю,
на ту тисячу гривень так і живу.
♪ Ох мені мама говорила, ♪
♪ щоб русича любить. ♪
♪ Гей я й мама, і ще тоді передбачала, ♪
♪ що не можу його й забути. ♪
♪ Тоді я же його й забуду, ♪
♪ коли закриються очі, ♪
♪ коли в піску засиплять тіло, ♪
♪ яке зігниє, як трава. ♪
Ох втомилася.
Ох я любила співати, Боже-ти.
Як улітку корови пасу, співаю у лісі.
Корови ходять, а я ходжу у лісі, співаю.
♪ Катерина вечерю варила, ♪
[Полісся
село Комори]
♪ Катерина вечерю варила, ♪
♪ до вечері стегно варила. ♪
♪  До вечері стегно варила. ♪
♪ Кипи, моя вечеронька, стиха, ♪
♪ кипи, моя вечеронька, стиха, ♪
♪ Ой мамо, подай жениха. ♪
♪ Кипи моя вечеронька стиха, ♪
♪ Нема, мамо, до любови жениха. ♪
♪ Вже вечеря стиха закипає. ♪
♪ Вже вечеря стиха закипає, ♪
♪ мій милий на поріг ступає. ♪
♪ Уже вечера стиха закипає, ♪
[Моляться] Отче наш, що єси на небесах,
нехай святиться ім'я Твоє;
Нехай прийде Царство Твоє;
Нехай буде воля Твоя, ─
як на небі, так і на землі.
Хліб наш насущний дай нам на щодень;
Прости нам провини наші,
як і ми пробачаємо винуватцям нашим;
І не введи нас у спокусу,
але визволи нас від лукавого.
Бо Твоє є Царство, і сила,
і слава, на віки вічні. Амінь.
Христос Воскрес!
Район зобов'язав голів колгоспу почати концерт.
Це не тільки з нашого села, а з інших.
Як вийдеш, то там співають
і там співають, вгадай, куди йти.
Тепер, якщо співаєш, то кажуть:
«То вже п'яний».
Тепер так.
Колись не були п'яні.
Збиралися і співали разом.
Тоді горілки не було.
♪ Ой ви гуси, сиві гуси, ♪
♪ не мутіть ви води. ♪
♪ Посватали дівчиноньку, ♪
♪  хлопець став,
наче хлопець молодий. ♪
Усе.
Ти трошки, може, не так, почав.
♪ Шумить дуб зелений, шумить... ♪
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]